bon je regarde top gun le regard top gun
a maintenant le regard d'organes
attention si tu des victimes avec un
fait déjà le royaume qui va avec fait
déjà le regard ok attention
regardez
la police si mon père
donc là la tnt tu vois quelqu'un soit
blessé gbagbo mais après c'était plus
compliqué que je vois de moins en moins
de loin mais ne gagnent pas moins 6,6 la
personne dans les yeux paradis tient pas
là fixé dans les couilles
la zone thorgan première fois elle est
jeune à la
musique ne veut pas de musique tu
connais pas des yeux rien tu regardes tu
fixes et la toussaint de top gun tu la
connais tu lui dis [ __ ] si tu arrives
à email il m'a dans son viseur evans son
viseur comme toi c'est ça tu vois tu vas
arrêter de me regarder dans
be there tu peux plus rien à faire là tu
lâches pas si c'est une torpille
abalo reçoit rien du tout
prenez break tant pis je te lis ça
marche tout le temps abbas a le regard
togo ou deuxième petite fille que tu
donnes tu fixes quelqu'un est pas dans
les yeux
ça représente sur le front la personne
extrêmement déranger parce que seulement
que tu regardes mathieu je fais ça moi
qui ai fait ça ouais bah voilà alors
comme ça vous regarde et la personne
dans les cheveux on a tué cinq personnes
exactement et la personne ne comprend
pas alors moi j'ai pas cannes après
c'est juste pour faire une harka un bon
bah c'est toi tu gagnes pour tout et
n'importe quoi toi je sais les basses
j'avoue que la retraite des poissons de
cette offre était à la haye s'est soldée
pour drôle surtout la réponse de daniel
un
daniel mais maintenant que j'y pense
c'est vrai que ça a été rapide et on
regarde top gun toi
c'est pas mal tu peux
faire moi je préfère m me regarde
topshop
badb toria mélangez pas tout bien
compris mais même si c'est moi tu crois
vraiment quelque chose à sauver 100
hybride annoncé nous aller alors lots
alors ça que le trèfle six ans que tu
bosses maximum des devises le bisou et
de titane et tu veux tuer l'ennemi mc
kelle m'exciterait
c'est qu'un excès la guichetière a
un petit goût de revenez-y non pas parce
que t'es allé dire
je peux dire si ge est à l'évidence un
jour ma promesse de cet été ouais bah
oui oui oui c'est quoi la scène nahda à
rabat cet été vous les produits ah bon
j'ai pas de vulgaires même à nos mamans
s'étaient battus dans ce qu il vous fait
qu alors veillez à vous que je peux en
régime si tu étais là
[Applaudissements]